النوويه الايرانيه ليس المشكله الوحيده
التي تواجه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو لديه مشاكل كثيره في الداخل قد
تؤثر على مواجهه النووي الايراني بل وقد
تعصف بحكومته العنوان الاساسي هو انقسام
الجيش هناك وزيران للدفاع نتنياهو عينه
احد مساعديه في حزب النقود يؤاف جلنطا
وزيرا للدفاع لكنه لضغوط اليمين وعين
وزيرا اخر للدفاع بتصل
ذلك بمنصب وزير دفاع مختص في الشؤون
المدنيه للخروج من المازق المفارقه
بالمناسبه الناس هرب من الجيش ولم يؤدي
الخدمه العسكريه هذا بجانب وجود اليمين
وزير الامن القومي الذي يتولى مسؤوليه حرس
الحدود في الضفه الغربيه هذه الامور تجعل
الجيش بثلاثه رؤوس امر يحذر منه مسؤولون
عسكريون سابقون الذين يؤكدون ان ذلك سيؤثر
على اكبر مشكله تواجه بن ابيب وهي تحديث
القوات البريه والانتقال الى خطط عسكريه
شامله لكن هناك رسائل تطمينيه تخرج من
المسؤولين وهناك قياده واحده للجيش رئيس
الاركان الجديد هرتزي اهلي اذا الانقسام
في الجيش ليس المشكله الوحيده هناك ازمه
داخليه اخرى غير مسبوقه طرفاها الحكومه
والمحكمه العليا وعنوانها هو الصداع على
صلاحيات القضاء خلفيه الازمه قد تفسر
احتدامها الان خلال السنوات الماضيه باتت
احزاب اليمين الاسرائيلي تؤمن بان النخبه
القضائيه تقف امام تنفيذ اجندتها ترى في
المحكمه العليا عقب امام توسيع مشروعها
الاستيطاني في الضفه الغربيه لكن لنعد
للشراره الاولى عندما قرر نتنياهو ترشيح
وزير القضاء الحالي يريف اليفين للمنصب لم
يكن الاختيار عشوائيا فلدين هو من اوائل
السياسيين اليمنيين الذين طرحوا مشروع
تغيير الصلاحيات السلطه
فضائيه حتى قبل نتنياهو بحد ذاته اما
الشراره الثانيه للازمه فاندلعت في الثامن
عشر من ديسمبر الماضي عندما استبعدت
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه رئيس حزب شاص
درعي من منصبه الوزري كوزير للصحه
والداخليه ضربه قويه تقود اتفاقات نتنياه
الائتلافيه وربما حتى قد تؤدي الى حل
حكومته اذا ما قرر حزب شاص الانسحاب منها
القرار القضائي يدعم نظريات الحزب التي
تتهم القضاء بملاحقه زعيمها منذ ادانته
بتلقي رشه اثناء توليه وزاره الداخليه في
عام
1999 بسبب تحيزات طائفيه وتحديدا خلفيته
الشرقيه كيف جاء قرار عدم القانونيه تعيين
اريا درعي في منصب منصب حكومي وقتها
وبموافقه 10 بموافقه 10 من 11 قاضيا لكن
اللافت هو ان التسعه قضاه من الموافق
الموافقين العشره كانوا من اصول اشكنزيه
والعاشر كان عربيا اما القاده الوحيد الذي
لم يؤيد بطلنا تعيين درعي كوزير فكان من
اصول شرقيه